>> Bret: WE WILL SEE WHAT
COMES NEXT.
A GENTLEMAN, WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
BACK IN THE U.S. CAPITOL ANOTHER
DAY OF TESTIMONY FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER ATTORNEY AND
FIXER, TODAY'S SESSION UNLIKE
WEDNESDAYS WAS HELD IN PRIVATE.
THERE HAS BEEN A VERY PUBLIC
REACTION BY REPUBLICANS TO SOME
OF MICHAEL COLLINS STATEMENTS
YESTERDAY.
CHIEF INTELLIGENT CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE'S LAP TONIGHT
ON CAPITOL HILL.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THE TESTIMONY CONCLUDED
WITHIN THE LAST HOUR WITH COHEN
MAKING A BRIEF PUBLIC STATEMENT.
>> AS I SAID I AM COMMITTED TO
TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> THE CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO
WILLIAM BARR ALLEGES MICHAEL:
PERJURED HIMSELF DURING
WEDNESDAY'S PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
>> I DID NOT WANT TO GO TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I WAS OFFERED JOBS.
>> "PROSECUTORS IN THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK WHERE HE
PLED GUILTY TO BANK AND TAX
FRAUD AS WELL IS LYING.
DURING AND AFTER THE CAMPAIGN HE
PRIVATELY TOLD FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES INCLUDING HIS TEXT
MESSAGES THAT HE WAS EXPECTED TO
GIVEN A PROMINENT ROLE IN TITLE
OF THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
HIS ATTORNEY LENNY DAVIS CALLED
THE REFERRAL BASELESS AND DRIVEN
BY TWO PRO-TRUMP COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THEN THERE IS HIS CNN INTERVIEW
FOUR DAYS AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> THERE IS ABSOLUTELY A CHANCE.
>> THERE WAS OTHER PUSHBACK.
ON TWITTER, WIKILEAKS AT ITS
EDITOR NEVER SPOKE TO PUT A
COOPERATIVE ROGER STONE ABOUT
HACKING DEMOCRATIC EMAILS AS HE
TESTIFIED.
>> HE TOLD MR. TRUMP THAT HE HAD
JUST GOTTEN OFF THE PHONE WITH
JULIAN SOUNDS.
THERE WOULD BE A MASSIVE DUMP OF
EMAILS THAT WOULD DAMAGE HILLARY
CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN.
>> HIS LAWYER RUDY GIULIANI SAID
HIS TESTIMONY THAT HE WAVED
ATTORNEY-CLIENT
ATTORNEY CLIENT
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
MR. TRUMP REPEATED HIS CRITICISM
OF HIS FORMER LAWYER AND
SO-CALLED FIXER.
>> HE SAID NO COLLUSION WITH THE
RUSSIAN HOAX.
I WONDER WHY HE DIDN'T LIE ABOUT
THAT TOO.
>> IT UNDERSCORED AN APPEARANCE
BY DEMOCRATS AWAY FROM RUSSIA
COLLUSION TO ALLEGED FRAUDULENT
PRACTICES BY DRUM.
>> DID HE EVER PROVIDE
INFLATABLE ASSETS TO INSURANCE
COMPANY?
>> YES.
>> WHERE WERE THE COMMITTEE FIND
MORE INFORMATION?
DO WE NEED TO REVIEW HIS
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS AND HIS TAX
RETURNS TO COMPARE THEM?
>> YES.
>> REPUBLICANS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE DEMOCRATS APPEARING SHIFTING
AND STRATEGY WHILE DISMISSING
SUGGESTIONS THAT HE FACES MORE
LEGAL AND POLITICAL TROUBLE.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT TROUBLE IS
THERE.
I THINK THE FOCUS IS SHIFTING.
>> THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WILL
RECALL COHEN MARCH 6 FOR MORE
TESTIMONY.
>> HE WAS FULLY COOPERATIVE AND
ANSWERED ALL OF OUR QUESTIONS
AND THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
EXCRUCIATING TIME FOR HIM.
>> THEY ANNOUNCED ANOTHER PUBLIC
HEARING FOR MARCH 14TH WITH A
RUSSIAN BORN BUSINESS ASSOCIATE
WHO WORKED WITH COHEN TO MARKET
THE 2016 REAL ESTATE PROJECT AS